let's talk
about the 2020 election and what my approach
is going to be because we're quickly getting
into the 2020 election in earnest and this
is going to be, I believe, an uglier election
than we have maybe ever seen in the modern
political era.
I'll tell you how and why that's going to
manifest the, let's set it up.
It's January 2nd.
The first votes in the democratic primary
are coming up in just a month.
We have debate number seven for the democratic
candidates in a couple of weeks.
Donald Trump is increasingly starting to campaign
for reelection in a serious manner.
As serious as he does it.
This is going to be an ugly election in ways
that may differ from past ugliness.
So think back to the Clinton days, there was
an attempt, um, pretty late in the 20, in
the 1992 election to attack bill Clinton by
publicizing a supposedly black loved child
that bill Clinton had.
If you watch the documentary, the war room,
which is an excellent documentary, you see
bill Clinton's advisers at the time, James
Carville, strategists, advisors, advisors,
James Carville and George Stephanopoulos deal
with this possible smear about bill Clinton
with a black loved child in real time.
And that was very ugly in its own way.
Um, in the 20 2008 campaign, the extreme racism
that we saw against Barack Obama.
So there has been ugliness.
2016 was very ugly in its own way, but if
you thought that the Hillary has Parkinson's
conspiracy theories were ugly.
If you thought Trump making fun of how candidates
look was ugly.
If you thought Trump attacking Megan Kelly
about a bloody, you know what was ugly?
Just wait until the 2020 election ramps up.
There's a really good piece by a conservative
Jonah Goldberg in the Los Angeles times about
this, and even if you don't agree with Jonah
Goldberg's politics or his analysis of candidates,
which I don't, he astutely points out that
Donald Trump in 2016 had nothing to lose.
He didn't think he was going to be the nominee.
He was already planning on what to do once
he lost the nomination, how to capitalize
on maybe coming in a respectable second or
third place.
Donald Trump is now the incumbent, and even
if he didn't want this thing to begin with,
he does not want to lose, and he is an impeached
president, which is driving him absolutely
up a wall.
We'll talk about that a little bit later.
Being president does not at all seem to have
matured.
Donald Trump, if anything, he's more childish
and unhinged than ever.
And then you add to this a bunch of different
things add to this that um, he has this fragile
cognitive state in which he finds himself
or an emotional imbalance or whatever it is.
Something there adds on to the 2016 Trump
that we saw add to this, that in 2016, Donald
Trump did not have the right wing media, uh,
supporting him all along.
Remember that they eventually came to support
Donald Trump, but early in the 2016, uh, D
a Republican primary really even in 2015,
Fox news was not with Donald Trump.
A lot of that right wing apparatus that now
basically is with Trump, at least for now,
they were not with them in 2016.
So he has the benefit of that, which means
he will be able to get away with even more
knowing that that right wing media apparatus
is going to defend them.
Now that may change.
I said it's possible Fox would abandoned Trump
in 2020.
Hypothetically.
It doesn't seem like it's going to happen
unless that changes.
We expect that the support is going to continue.
This will further enable Donald Trump.
Add to that Donald Trump's friendship with
tabloid propagandists, David pepper pecker
rather, which gives Trump more resources and
wherewithal to publish and push really horrible
attacks on whoever is the eventual democratic
nominee.
Over my vacation last week, I had the opportunity
to read almost all of Ronan Farrow's book
catch and kill, and that is another recipe
for a campaign that will reach levels of ugly
that we have not seen before in his piece.
Jonah Goldberg is already citing two early
examples of the type of campaign that this
will be saying.
Quote, first on Friday night, the president
retweeted and then deleted a post naming the
whistleblower in the Ukraine affair.
If candidate Trump had done something like
that, criticism from the right would have
been deafening.
Then on Sunday night at an event in Milford,
New Hampshire, the famously tactile Biden
was greeted by a handful of protesters.
Don't touch kids.
You pervert.
One man who claims not to be a Trump supporter.
Shouted a woman started a bar, a brief chat
of quid pro Joe.
If you live in a swing state, it is going
to be even extra kooky, crazy ugly in 2020
if you live in a red state, a lot of that
ugliness is probably already infected like
a virus.
Many of your friends and neighbors and you're
already in the thick of it and probably have
been for the last year or a year and a half.
One thing I'm looking at doing for myself,
for my own sanity, and I know that some people
have noticed this, I've gotten emails from
people saying, David, I'm seeing you sort
of pull back on social media.
I'm looking at how much more can I pull back
on social media without losing touch with
the audience, without losing touch with, you
know, the usefulness of those tools to an
end up independent media show like this one
because it's just too toxic.
And I know lots of you have been feeling this
for awhile.
Uh, I talked about this with Joe Rogan last
June when I was on his program.
Let me know what you think.
Let me know what you were planning on doing
when it comes to, it's not just the ugliness
that we're expecting, but it's also the even
bigger effect of these algorithmic echo chambers
that are created and perpetuated on social
media.
I want to hear from you.
Leave a reply.
If you're watching on YouTube, send me a tweet
at deep Pacman.
Otherwise, and make sure to follow both at
D Pacman and David Pakman show on Twitter.
I want to hear from you.
We'll probably follow up tomorrow or early
next week about that.